I want to discuss Donald Trump's plan so
far to tell you how horrifying and
backwards Donald intends to make his
administration now as a reminder from
yesterday I advised Democrats as did
Italian Luigi Zingales who experienced
the Berlusconi reign in Italy Democrats
should work with Trump where there is
overlap infrastructure
non-interventionist Middle East foreign
policy a few other areas but there isn't
a huge amount of overlap with what
Donald Trump is saying that he is going
to do so let's go through what Trump has
said so far that he plans to do as
president
Donald number one a president Donald has
a creationist vice president who wants
to teach creationism in school Mike
Pence avoided accepting evolution
numerous times he believes in
creationism personally he says we should
teach it to our kids alongside evolution
this is the vice president now selected
by president elect Donald what is that
going to do to education during Trump's
administration more on that a little bit
later
number two Trump is going to start trade
wars that will hurt Americans he's going
to increase prices on products for
Americans via the trade wars he alleges
he is going to wage won't really help
anybody as we've expressed before China
has ways to retaliate and we've talked
about that Europe can also retaliate not
good not good for the average American
consumer number three
Trump is going to bring in Attorney
General Jeff Sessions who expressed that
he liked the KKK until he found out that
they smoked pot and also said that no
good people smoked pot this is very very
dangerous we have someone who is
full-fledged drug war type and this is
an absolute and utter disaster number
four a Donald Trump has said that he is
going to basically kill the new
regulations that were due to go in
effect on December 1st which would
demand that companies pay time and a
half overtime to voters who make under
$47,000 a year Ross story said that the
plan is likely to be one of the first
measures that trum
we'll destroy when he takes office on
January 20th not sounding great for
middle America I must say number 5
Donald Trump is going to be appointing
an education secretary Betsy DeVos from
the Acton Institute the Acton Institute
has actually written that they don't see
child labor as a bad thing but actually
something that really should be looked
at because it can be really good for
kids to have a long day's work and a
load of sweat it's a load of something
that I think we can say that will be
Donald Trump's education secretary
number six we have now learned from
rinse Priebus that climate science
denial will be Donald Trump's default
position Trump has hired Myron Ebell a
denier to lead his EPA transition
completely counter to almost all science
and we will talk about that in more
detail later in the show number seven as
I told you last week Donald Trump wants
to end net neutrality he doesn't really
know much of what it is but he knows
enough to know that he is against it and
that is incredibly dangerous for
independent media like our program and
many of our friends it is incredibly
dangerous in terms of strengthening the
oleg appellee that we have really a
monopoly in many cases for some of these
Internet service providers disaster
number eight Donald Trump wants to
defund NASA's climate research because
it has become political NASA research
can only become political when one
political party consistently fights
against science and facts and turns it
into politics and that is an absolute
embarrassment number nine we told you
that Donald Trump is going to be
implementing smaller tax cuts than he
promised during his campaign but what he
is going to be doing is giving the
biggest tax cuts to the richest
Americans the plan will cut taxes by 0.8
percent for the vast majority of people
oh and fourteen plus percent for the top
one percent really making a stand for
the little man ha just like Donald Trump
promised and number 10 I'm gonna dig
into this a lot later
once a year in prison for burning flags
or the stripping of citizenship I don't
want to get into that right now Pat
because we're gonna we're gonna delve
into that more later this is not about
politics or conservatism this is about
how will these policies make America
great again and more interestingly how
will it help middle-class Americans it's
very clear how it'll help the 1% right
we get that how are these policies going
to help the group that Donald Trump said
he would help and that by and large in
many parts of the country bought into it
that Trump would help them right totally
I mean Donald Trump apparently ran a
populist campaign or a pseudo populist
campaign yeah but who in middle America
is really concerned about ending net
neutrality or cutting taxes on the top
one percent now it's just a sham what's
the counter to all of this from the
trumpets it's Oh David this is all a
premature critique because nothing is
official yet Trump hasn't actually been
sworn in if that's your counter-argument
you're basically saying you don't
believe the guy you voted for will do
what he's saying he will do what a
ringing endorsement defending your guy
by saying I don't know that he will
actually do the things that he says he
will do he won't be as bad as we say
because he's lying about what he will do
we're in for a bumpy ride aren't we Pat
if the trumpets have to defend their guy
by saying don't believe what he's
promising to do and don't get us wrong I
mean some of these promises he's made we
hope that he backs off of sure we'll
just have to see which ones he picks
yeah and we saw but with the Affordable
Care Act he's already going from it's a
total disaster that were getting rid of
to you know actually some of the
provisions in the Affordable Care Act
are quote very good so in every aspect
his supporters his base particularly his
base that is not very rich has been
completely bamboozled some of the things
they wanted him to do
he's already backed off of and now that
we're getting a sense of what he is
actually going to do we see that many of
those policies would be hugely damaging
to that base that so fervently supported
this guy send me your thoughts on this
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
is on twitter at david pakman show and
we have an excellent program for you
today I've talked about how people of
all ages but particularly Millennials
are owning cars less and participating
more in the sharing economy and one of
the more popular options is Zipcar which
gets you a car when you want it when you
need it they offer all sorts of cars
SUVs hybrids whatever you need it
includes insurance and it includes gas
you just pay for the time that you
actually use the car and you can reserve
the car online from your smartphone over
the phone then you unlock it with your
zip card each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
eleven hundred and sixteen hundred
pounds per year for our audience
Zipcar is offering twenty five dollars a
free driving credit if you sign up at
join zip car comm slash david support
our show reduce your carbon emissions
and you're spending on cars sign up at
join zip car comm slash david